(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Get it out, get it out.
Get it out.
(Kelly and audience cheering)
I don't know why I'm shocked.
But once again, you make
something casual very cool
and rock and roll.
- Thank you!
- Truly you are a fashion icon.
- I'm in a sweatshirt.
- [Kelly] No!
(audience cheering)
But you make everything look so flawless
and rock and roll and cool.
That's just true.
And you're a fashion icon.
So have you always been into fashion,
like even when you were, like, younger?
- I always, I was born that way.
Like, I just love clothes, love makeup.
I'm like a visual person, I guess.
I could see the world through visuals.
- But not everybody sees like that.
Not every, like me, we are opposite.
Like, I didn't do any of this.
Candice did.
(Gwen laughing)
And so, I don't see like that, like-
- [Gwen] And It's weird for me
that you don't see like that.
Like, I'm like, how?
How do you not see like that?
- [Kelly] I know but-
- like, just the way I am.
- [Kelly] But it's art.
It's like some people don't see that.
- I've always been like
a thrift store shopper.
Like, I just love anything vintage.
- I came out looking different.
- [Gwen] Yeah. (laughs)
- I shop through thrift stores too, Gwen.
But like, I didn't even
come out looking like this.
I came out looking like,
"She went to a thrift store."
It was very different.
But I love that it's all organic for you.
I love that you have the
line. That's so cool.
And you have like your signature look
that everybody loves too.
I think when I saw you on Instagram
when you first came out that it
was like your signature
red-like lip look that came out.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That was so cool.
- And I-
- for all of us nerds were like, you know,
we were like, yeah, just a girl.
Like, you know, back in the day,
like, you know what I'm saying?
And you think you were weird back then,
but all of us were weird,
and you made us feel like we weren't,
so that's what was so cool about you.
- [Gwen] Aw.
- Anyway, that's all.
(audience cheering)
But, we thought we'd run through
some of your past looks, though,
to get the stories behind
them, so is that okay?
- [Gwen] Yes.
- Okay, okay.
So, let's start with this one.
From your No Doubt days.
So where did this look?
What were you thinking?
(audience cheering)
- [Gwen] It feels like yesterday.
I mean, honestly, time just goes so fast.
- [Kelly] It does.
- [Gwen] It's crazy.
I mean, honestly back then, like I said,
I didn't have a stylist
or a makeup artist.
And once we started
really getting on tour,
like we basically did the
"Just a Girl" video, right?
And it was our first video really,
and went to the airport,
and then I didn't come home
for like two and a half years.
Like, we were on tour.
Like, it was like, bye.
Like, "Mom, I'll be back."
"No, I'm not."
And I still lived at home and I was 26.
So I didn't, because I was gone on tour,
but all my stuff was there.
And so, when we were on tour, it was like,
well, after a while I needed
clothes, you know what I mean?
Like, I needed costumes.
We'd wear the same thing
over and over again.
Everyone smelled like, it was like-
- Yep.
- It was like I was super unorganized.
I have one makeup.
- I have shared
a bus with boys.
- [Gwen] Yes. It's disgusting.
- It's Different.
- [Gwen] But those actual pants,
I think that was when I found this girl
through my manager that would
just make clothes for me.
So like, she would go downtown,
she would send me like
literally a piece of paper
with like swatches stapled to it.
And I'd say, "Okay, do these pants."
And I would do it from the road.
And then, she would FedEx
out a pair of pants.
- I love that
- [Gwen] It was very homegrown.
Like, no-
- [Kelly] I know. But that's
what I mean, it's so natural.
And then you had a
line, it all made sense.
But I love that you look like
you're just so rock and roll.
Like, the person that
passes you on the street,
they're like, "Man, I
wanna look like that."
And then, you just walk on stage.
Like, that's what I loved about this look.
That was my input right there.
But wait, what was the occasion here?
I love this dress so much.
- [Gwen] Okay, that is-
- [Kelly] This is is so pretty.
- [Gwen] That's Janina.
- Wow.
- [Gwen] Thank you.
The designer is Janina.
That was my first public date
with Blake Shelton, actually.
(audience screaming)
- I didn't know that.
- [Gwen] It was.
- I love that
- And it was the Oscar's
Vanity Fair Party.
I think I played at the party,
and then we went out that night so.
It was like, he never does red carpet,
now that I know him.
Like, that was like, I
think we did a red carpet.
It was kind of a red carpet.
It was raining that night and yeah,
- [Kelly] You look beautiful.
- I'll always,
like that melts me when I see it,
because it's like such
a moment for me, yeah.
A good one.
- [Kelly] I didn't know that.
But you look like Chris
de Burgh, "Lady In Red."
Like, you're walking in the room,
and the song was written for you.
Like, that song back in the day.
I just aged myself, so
- [Gwen] I love that song
- I love that song so much.
Okay, so wait, where was this shot taken?
What about this one?
- Okay, that's-
- [Kelly] I love it.
- [Gwen] Thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience hooting)
- [Gwen] That's Vera Wang.
- [Kelly] I love her.
- [Gwen] It was at the Met ball this year.
And she's just so talented.
Vera's been doing it for so long.
And so, to be able to work with her,
it was just amazing to
wear a couture dress
made for me.
Like, when the sketch came it was like,
it looked exactly like that.
Like, they drew my face,
the hair, everything.
And it was weird to go from a sketch
to like real life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that was one of those crazy moments
where I was gonna have a makeup artist
do my makeup and her mom had an emergency,
and she had to leave.
So I luckily had my makeup bag
and did my own makeup that night.
So it was one of those like crazy moments.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
(audience clapping)
- It was exciting, but.
- I see another difference between
I see you came out looking like that
after you did your makeup.
(Gwen and Kelly laughing)
Would've been very different from me.
- I wanna do your makeup.
- Anyone can 'cause I don't.
No, I love that though,
because I think that's the coolest thing
about fashion is sometimes we forget,
it's such an art form,
and it's so beautiful,
and you literally look like
a walking piece of art.
- Honestly, I don't even
think people understand
like, these designers are so talented
and creative, and I walked into the room,
and they had those flowers.
They have like hundreds of 'em
that they had made by hand,
like, deciding where
they're gonna put them.
It was literally-
- Like in the moment, like
while you're worrying about-
- [Gwen] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Gwen] Yeah. It's just
to me, like, beyond a dream
to be able to work with someone so gifted
that has had such an impact.
And, you know, Vera's done
so many wedding dresses,
and a big part of
people's lives, you know,
with her vision.
So that was an amazing moment
and never thought that I would get to-
- And still pull up that crop top, ma'am.
Bam, bam, bam!
I'm like, after three children, whatever.
So how's it going at "The Voice"?
Is it fun this season?
- It's-
- [Kelly] It's weird for me.
- It's weird, you'll
be here talking to you,
like, I feel like I'm
cheating on you or something.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- No, I'm so excited.
I was so excited when
they announced Camila.
'Cause I was like, "Well, wait,
I feel like the same
kinda personality," yeah.
- I was gonna say, she has
the same mentality as you.
Like, she doesn't care about
glam or about what she wear.
Like, she's just kinda like a,
she's just talks a lot
and she's competitive,
and she's you.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- [Gwen] Like, yeah.
- Yeah, I was like when
when she came on the show,
I was like, I'm so excited
for her to go against Blake.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, and actually, it was crazy 'cause,
like, the first few days,
I felt like it took her
like a couple days to really get there,
and after the first "Shut
up, Blake" then it was on.
- [Kelly] It was on.
- Finally, she goes,
"Shut up, Blake."
And then, it was like this whole like-
- They're open.
- [Gwen] Thing happened. It was, yeah.
- It's a really great
moment for the rest of us.
- It feels good to say, "Shut up, Blake."
- [Kelly] Yeah, it really does.
So wait, so do you ever
feel like you're coaching?
I always feel like,
because we're moms as well,
do you ever feel like
you're kind of the mama?
You feel like very
maternal with your team?
- [Gwen] For sure.
- I do.
- For me, honestly.
And I know that you're like this,
and I'm not sure Blake
is 'cause Blake isn't.
But when I coach, when
I'm actually in those,
like, reality days when we
get to really work with them,
that's like my favorite part.
Like besides glam, obviously,
that's my favorite part.
But I love being in there
and watching them grow,
like, right before my
eyes, and it sometimes-
- Specially young ones like Carter.
- [Gwen] Yes.
And sometimes it's like,
you think you're gonna say something like,
"Why don't you try this?"
And you're doing that because you have
the knowledge from all the year.
I do, from all those
years and I look back,
and it's really fun for
me to go "try this,"
and then they do it.
And you think in your mind
it's not gonna do anything
and then it does.
- Yeah.
- [Gwen] And not even just me,
but the whole room is like "Oh, my gosh."
Like he came to life, like,
right before our eyes.
So it's-
- Sometimes you have to instill
that confidence, yeah, yeah.
- [Gwen] It's a really incredible show.
And I love doing it so much.
I'm so happy to be back.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I know.
I can't wait.
I can't wait to watch the chemistry.
And you, so we were talking about,
you launched your own line.
It's called, "GXVE Beauty."
So why did you name it that?
'Cause I assume you like to give beauty,
like you give that kinda gift.
That's awesome.
- [Gwen] Yeah,
it's definitely one of those things.
I feel like, with makeup,
you put your makeup on and you're giving
to other people with
what you're doing, right?
Like you put the effort in,
and you don't go around
looking at yourself
all day long unless you're
like Instagraming and all that.
But I'm saying like,
it's also, like, this time in my life,
everybody knows I went through
a really challenging time
a few years ago, and I
kinda reassessed everything.
I had to start over
with so many things and-
- just hard to do.
- [Gwen] It's really hard.
And I just was like,
"What am I gonna do with
the rest of my life?"
And I know I have to
be creative in some way
or I'll just feel like a loser.
- It's your purpose.
- [Gwen] Yeah.
And makeup, before music it was makeup.
I was a makeup artist,
you know, at the mall.
- [Kelly] Oh, you were?
- Yes.
- I didn't know that, no.
- [Gwen] Not for a long time,
(audience clapping)
but it was like my dream.
Because I actually worked
in Plaza Sportswear
and like, you know, polyester
pants for older women.
And I really did actually enjoy that
'cause I was good at that too.
And I'm not.
(Kelly laughing)
- I was like, I would
because women come in,
and they'd be desperate.
Like, "Help me find an outfit."
And I would love that.
- It's a gift to be able
to know how to help that situation.
- [Gwen] But I do, I love that.
And so, I just looked
up for the girls over
on the counter that I was like,
"I wanna be one of those girls."
Like, I wanna be behind the
counter. I know I can do it.
And finally, they just open the door.
They didn't even train me.
They didn't tell me what to do.
They were like, "Just make
a display and sell makeup."
And so, I started doing it.
But the joy of it was,
when people would come in
and just want, like, free samples
or want you to do their makeup for free
'cause they were gonna go out or whatever,
and maybe buy something from you,
but it was like the way they felt
when I would do their makeup.
The way I feel when I wake
up and look at myself,
and then after my makeup's done,
like, it's just that feeling.
So I feel it's like this giving feeling.
So, that's kinda where it came from.
- [Kelly] No, it's a blessing.
It's a blessing for people that can do it,
because I literally, like,
come into this studio
like a different human, and I
like that human, she's great.
She looks fine.
But like, when my glam squad,
I call them Harry Potter, collectively.
Because literally, what you're able to do
when you can do that is
you transform a person.
- [Gwen] And you feel different.
- And you feel different.
You carry yourself differently, I agree.
- I'm surprised because you love crafting,
you're super artistic.
- [Kelly] I love that art.
- I would think that you
will be good at makeup.
I think you can be.
- I'm also highly allergic.
- [Gwen] I believe in you.
- I'm highly allergic, yeah, yes.
- That is true.
Well, my line is all
clean, so there's that.
- Oh, I was gonna ask you,
and I didn't wanna ask
you in case it wasn't.
Okay. So yeah, it is.
(Gwen laughing)
I was like, I didn't wanna, like out you.
But that's amazing 'cause
for people like me,
I've struggle to find things,
especially eye stuff and that's why.
- It is hard, and the thing is that
it's super challenging
'cause when you're creating
the formulas for clean makeup,
it's like, to have high performance,
like real artistic-level makeup
that's like really dense
colors and stuff like that,
it is challenging, like,
for it to finally be out.
And then we also launched this,
this is really cool if you love makeup or-
- Are you talking about
the community part of it?
- [Gwen] Yes, Yeah.
- I'm so glad you're talking about this
'cause I saw you talking
about an interview.
I think it was with Seth
Meyers, and I love this part.
Tell everybody about it.
They get to be a part of it, right?
- [Gwen] Yeah, there is a
makeup community out there.
There's people that blog makeup,
that love makeup, that are obsessed
like I am with makeup,
and they're already doing it.
And there's also like
people that just follow me
that promote me because
they feel like they want to,
and I'm like, "I wanna feel like,
at this point in my life,
how do I include them?"
So basically, we started
this ambassador program
where you can actually just sit at home
and sell the makeup from your phone
and make a commission off of it.
- But they come up with
their own stuff too.
That's how they can sell it too.
- [Gwen] They can do their own tutorials.
- That's what I mean, yeah.
- They get like all of
the information from us,
and they get a code,
and then people can shop
through their Instagram,
however they wanna do it,
and they get the commissions.
So, it's just cool.
They're doing what they're
probably already doing anyways,
but they're gonna get some money for it.
So, I think it's kinda cool to be able to
- I think it's cool.
(audience laughing)
You probably got commission
anytime you sold.
- [Gwen] Yes.
- I think it's cool,
that full circle moment.
- It's just like a fun
kinda game to play, really.
Just be out there and it's so fun for me
to troll on all these people
that are taking the makeup
and like making it theirs.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
'Cause they do things with
it that I wouldn't do.
You know, it's just a very creative place
to express yourself.
- But might inspire you
to do something, inspire other people.
It's very cool.
I like it, I like the full circle.
Wait, can we see the makeup?
Oh hey. What up, Trey?
What's up Justin?
- [Gwen] Oh my god. That-
- [Kelly] Look at that tray.
- Oh, they made it. It's so pretty.
- Look at "Kelly Clarkson
Show" coming through.
(audience clapping)
I'm like, I didn't see that before.
This is so cute.
Okay, so wait, we brought this up to show
because well, Gwen has a special
surprise for everyone here.
GXVE Beauty by Gwen Stefani.
She might not have known
but it's happening.
(Gwen and Kelly laughing)
- Now you're saying it, oh yeah.
- GXVE Beauty by Gwen Stefani is a clean,
high-performance color cosmetics brand
creative for the community
of creative people who love makeup.
You can shop their
products at givebeauty.com.
But today, everyone in the audience
is going home with Gwen's signature look
worth over 200 dollars.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew!
(audience cheering)